here in the United States on this
President's Day the long and
distinguished life of former President
Jimmy Carter is approaching its end in a
statement Saturday the Carter Center
revealed that the 98 year old has quote
decided to spend his remaining time at
home with his family and to receive
hospice care it's a decision that
follows a series of hospital stays and
our Robert Costa has made his way to
Carter's hometown of Plains Georgia
where the former president was born
where he lived most of his life where he
returned after the White House Bob good
morning
Good morning Tony President Carter's
decision has prompted world leaders
including President Biden to offer their
support and admiration it has also
pushed this tight-knit community to come
together
what does President Carter mean to you
he is
that example
that the Bible talks about friends and
family of Jimmy Carter gathered Sunday
at Maranatha Baptist in Plains Georgia
where the former president has long
taught Sunday school on this occasion it
was Carter's niece Kim Fuller who spoke
movingly of her uncle and former first
lady Rosalind Carter dear heavenly
father and we just thank you for giving
us the opportunity to to be in the lives
of these people Deacon Zach Steele said
the people of plains have grown closer
in recent days sharing stories about the
man they've known best as a neighbor I
think it's a remarkable Testament to his
character that you can be the most
powerful person in the world but when
you come back home
you're just Jamie Jan Williams who
taught the former president's daughter
in school recalled a man with a dry
sense of humor who has always been
dedicated to this small southern town
the first sign that I asked him when he
won
was what are you going to do when you
get through being president and he said
I'm going to come back to flames and
live the rest of my life The Carter
Center on Sunday did not offer
additional updates on the 39th
president's health
a day earlier Carter's grandson Jason
wrote on Twitter that his grandparents
are at peace and as always their home is
full of love Jill Stuckey is one of the
Carter's closest friends and the manager
of the nearby Carter Museum I went to
church earlier today and two words come
to mind Grace and Grit
that's that's President Carter he's
never giving up and he is always going
to help people until he takes his last
breath
last night on the eve of President's Day
several long-time Carter advisors told
CBS news that they expect the former
president to remain tough until the end
to never quit and as ever to have his
wife of more than 75 years Rosalind at
his side Nate
Bob you're right Grace and grit and I'll
add in purpose thank you so much